PROFESSOR: Levinson's theorem,
in terms of derivations,
that we do in this
course, this is probably
the most subtle derivation
of the semester.
It's not difficult, but
it's kind of interesting
and a little subtle.
And it's curious, because
it relates to things that
seem to be fairly unrelated.
But the key thing
that one has to do
is you have to use something.
How all of the
sudden are you going
to relate phase shifts
to bound states?
The one thing you
have to imagine
is that if you have
a potential and you
have states of a potential,
if the potential changes,
the states change.
But here comes
something very nice.
They never appear or disappear.
And this is something probably
you haven't thought about this
all that much.
Because you had, for example,
a square, finite square well.
If you made this more deep,
you've got more bound states.
If you made it less deep,
the bound states disappear.
What does it mean the
bound states disappear?
Nothing, really can disappear.
What really is happening,
if you have the bounds,
the square well.
You have a couple of
bound states, say.
But then you have an infinity
of scatterings states.
And as you make this
potential less shallow,
the last bound state
is approaching here.
And at one state,
it changes identity
and becomes a scatterings
state, but it never gets lost.
And how, when you make
this deeper and deeper
you get more state, is
the scattering state
suddenly borrowing, lending
you a state that goes down?
The states never get
lost or disappear.
And you will, say, how
could you demonstrate that?
That sounds like
science fiction,
because, well, there's
infinitely many states here.
How do you know it borrowed one?
Well, you can do it by putting
it in a very large box.
And then the states
here are going
to be finitely
countable and discrete.
And then you can
track and see indeed
how the states become bound.
So you'd never lose
or gain states.
And that's a very, very powerful
statement about quantum states
in a system.
So this is what
we're going to need
to prove Levinson's theorem.
So Levinson theorem theorem--
so it relates a number of
bound states of the potential
to the excursion
of the phase shift.
So let's state it completely.
It relates the number N of
bound states of the potential
to the excursion, excursion of
the phase from E equals 0 to E
equals infinity.
So in other words, it says
that N is 1 over pi delta of 0
minus delta of
infinity, a number
of bound states
of your potential
is predicted by the behavior of
the phase shift of scattering.
So how do we do this?
This is what we want to prove.
So consider, again, our
potential of range R and 0
here and here is x.
And I want you to be
able to count states,
but discovering states are
a continuous set of states.
So in order to
count states, we're
going to put a
wall here, as well,
at some big distance L
much bigger than A than R.
And we're going, therefore--
now the states are
going to be quantized.
They're never going be
quite scatterings states.
They're going to look
like scatterings states.
But they're precisely
in the way that they
vanished at this point.
Now you would say, OK, that's
already a little dangerous
to be.
Oh, you've changed the
problem a little, yes.
But we're going
to do the analysis
and see if the result depends
on L. If it doesn't depend on L
and L is very large, we'll
take the limit this L goes
to infinity.
And we claim, we have answer.
So we argue that L is
a regulator, regulator
to avoid a continuum,
continuum of states
to avoid that
continuum of states.
All right, so let's
begin to count.
To count this thing,
we start with the case
where there is no
potential again.
And why is that?
Because we're going
to try to compare
the situation with no
potential to the situation
with potential.
So imagine let V identical
is 0, no potential
and consider positive
energy states.
These are the only
states that exist.
There are no bound states,
because the potential is 0.
Well, the solutions
were found before, we
mentioned that these are what we
call phi effects or sine of kx.
But now we require that
phi of L is equal to 0,
because we do have
the wall there.
And therefore, si of kl must
be 0 and kl must be n pi and n
is 1, 2 to infinity.
You know we manage with the
wall to discretize this state,
because the whole world is now
an infinite, a very big box,
not infinite, but very big.
So you've discrete the state.
The separations are
microelectron volts,
but they are discrete.
You can count them.
And then with this
state over here,
we think of counting them.
And you say, well, I
can count them with n.
So if I imagine the
k line from 0 to 50,
the other states are
over, all the values of k.
And they could say,
well, I even want
to see how many states there
are in a little element dk.
And for the that you
would have that dk taken
a differential here
is dn times pi.
So of the number of states
that there are in dk, dn--
let me right here--
dn equals l over pi dk is
the number of positive energy
states in dk.
In the range dk, in
the range of momentum,
dk that little interval, there
are that many positive energy
eigenstates.
So far, so good.
So now let's consider
the real case.
Repeat for the case
there is some potential.
Well, you would say, well,
I don't know how to count.
I have to solve the problem
of when the potential makes
a difference.
But no, you do
know how to count.
So repeat for V
different from 0.
This time we have a
solution for x greater
than R. We know the solution.
This is our universal
solution with the phase.
So there you have the si
effect is e to i delta sine
kx plus delta of k.
That's a solution.
Yes, you have the
solution always.
You just don't
know what delta is.
But you don't know what delta--
you don't need to know what
delta is to prove the theorem,
You just need to
know it's there.
So here it goes.
And this time the wall will
also do the same thing.
We'll demand the si of x
vanishes for x equal L.
So this time we get that kx--
no kL plus delta of k is
equal to some other number n
prime times pi multiple of pi.
This phase-- this total phase
has to be a multiple of pi.
And what is n prime?
I don't know what is n prime?
It is some integers.
I don't know whether it starts
from 1, 2, 3 or from 100
or whatever.
The only thing we
care is that, again,
taking a little
differential, you
have dk times L
plus d delta, dk,
times dk is equal to
the dn prime times pi.
We take an infinitesimal version
of this equation, which again
tells me how many positive--
all these states are
positive energy states.
They have k.
So all these are
positive energy states.
So from this equation, we get
that dn prime is equal to L
over pi dk plus 1 over pi
d delta dk times dk, which
gives me if I know the dk,
again, the number of states
that you have in
that range of k,
You see it's like
momentum is now quantized.
So for any little
range of momentum,
you can tell how many
states there are.
And here it is how many states
there are, positive energy
states, positive.
This is the number of positive
energy states in dk with V
different from 0, here
is with V equal 0.